u.s elections need
thousands of people to make everything
work checking names
handing out ballots even doling out
those stickers
usually the majority of these temporary
workers are older but given their risk
for coronavirus
many said they would sit this year out
sending election officials scrambling
we're down about 50 so that's 20 000
people that we were trying to recruit to
be election judges
as a result the state of maryland is
closing about 80 percent of the places
where people usually vote but in some
cases they're opening up larger
facilities like this arena
hoping that just fewer workers can help
many more voters
all of these places are even on local
transportation routes um
in order to to be used as an early
voting center
or even as an election day vote center
uh
there are requirements that it be within
a certain distance to
the closest bus stop but during the
primary
fewer places meant longer lines in many
states election lawyers fear this
shortage of poll workers could be
exploited in some areas
to hurt democrats we've seen
unfortunately
more voters of color being affected by
those poll closures and consolidations
some counties have you know specifically
targeted
minority communities for these closures
and consolidations
so now superstar athletes like lebron
james and others are getting
involved using their celebrity and their
money to recruit poll workers
especially for minority areas scott
duncamel is the co-director of power the
polls
and he says they've been able to recruit
more than half a million
young people what we're doing is we're
uh
really trying to go where young people
are these days which means social media
and so uh one of the one of the the
reasons for our organization
is you know election officials don't
know how to run instagram ads don't know
how to run snapchat ads
um so we're really working closely with
platforms like snap uh to try to get
young people in
and i think we have succeeded in that
this is expected to be an election
like no other record turnout in the
midst of a pandemic
and a u.s president hoping to cast doubt
on the election's credibility
his opponents thinking creatively about
how to give him one
less reason to do that patty cohen al
jazeera maryland